well hi everybody it's really fun to be
the very last thing how many of you were
graduating okay Wow oh my god so I
really am like one of the last things
before you and graduation I'm really
excited about graduation I'm gonna put
on the robe and and March with you in my
role as an adjunct here and very excited
to hear Bill and Melinda Gates speak as
the commencement speakers so it is an
honor for me to be here I have had the
benefit I don't know if it's the benefit
or or the build-up of having been to
about 50 et ELLs myself and so as I
thought long and hard about what I
wanted to do today I thought back on
what which ETS have been the most
interesting to me personally and I
decided the ones that were the most fun
for me were the ones where a person
really talked about their early life and
particularly if they had gone to
Stanford about things about Stanford and
and things to think about you know
either
with Stanford itself or right after
graduation and then tell their lesson
learned lessons learned from their
entrepreneurial experience so that's
what I decided to do and and esteana
said we're gonna spend about the next 40
minutes doing that and then I've been
happy to do QA so without further ado
let me get going as you'll see I've been
to Stanford four times and I'm about to
have a fifth role here at Stanford
because my daughter is an incoming
freshman and she's in the room but I
won't embarrass her right now cuz she's
probably already cringing that I've
already said that so let me just get
right into it my first tour of duty at
Stanford anybody recognize this building
this is the Hoover Building it used to
be the Stanford Hospital and I was
actually born at the Stanford hospital
as Warren Buffett likes to say I really
feel like I won the ovarian lottery now
what does warren mean when he says that
he says for for most of us certainly for
people born in america the vast majority
of us can count ourselves among the
lucky who win the ovarian lottery
because i can really say that in this
situation being in Silicon Valley in I
was born in 58 so really in the early
60s and Beyond was a really incredible
time in place and a place
where I had you know enough food to eat
and education and all those sorts of
things and so it was very very fortunate
that my family was here my family hadn't
always been here though I'm actually the
first-generation American I'm the person
born American in my family my father was
a Russian and Romanian immigrant my
mother was a German immigrant my mother
only had an eighth grade education my
father did not finish college and they
came here looking for the proverbial
better life my dad was a very
entrepreneurial person he actually
worked anybody recognized that sign okay
so I have a lot of like like Silicon
Valley trivia landmark things in my
slides I should have like a quiz if you
could name all the locations you get a
prize or something this is on 101 it was
Ampex corporation one of the very early
technology companies in the valley there
actually were one of the patent holders
and creators of the video tape recorder
and my dad was an early employee there
he was an engineer he worked on the
bench he was patent holder for color
videotape and but he was never really
happy being in an inner organization
even the size of Ampex which at the time
play had a couple thousand employees so
my dad ended up quitting his job more
than once he actually quit once just
because he wanted to take the summer off
and they wouldn't let him and he decided
if he quit by the end of the summer they
wouldn't have found anyone and he could
get hired back this was obviously in the
era of pre stock options because he
would of course never do that today and
walk away from your auctions but he quit
a few times and I always came back and
got his job back but one year on he quit
and decided to become an entrepreneur so
he did that and he failed and in fact my
family my dad declared bankruptcy we
went through a very difficult financial
time my parents got divorced and in fact
my next Silicon Valley landmark some of
you have probably recognized this I hope
no mostly we've not spent too much time
in this particular establishment I
actually lived in the glass slipper
motel on El Camino for about a year and
attended junior high from the El Camino
glass slipper Motel so so I definitely
got to see some different walks of life
when my dad was working at Ampex we
actually were a pair
decent middle-class family and then we
ended up being not not so much and it
definitely ingrained in me the idea that
I needed to work really hard and not be
in the situation my mother was in whoo
with only an eighth grade education
really couldn't do better than get a
minimum-wage job working as a dishwasher
and server in a you know at school
cafeteria and so that was one of the
things that kicked me into being very
motivated to try to work really hard in
high school and to try to you know get
get a good education because my dad was
entrepreneurial and because we were
broke I also decided I needed to start
earning money so actually at the tender
age of 12 I started my first startup I
did puppet shows for children's birthday
parties and I came up with this idea
because some of my relatives who were in
Germany had sent me some sized puppets
and so I had that was one thing I had I
had a collection of Psych puppets and I
thought well what can I do with these
and I decided that maybe it would be a
good idea to have put on a show and and
and rent myself out to mothers who
needed to entertain their children for
children's birthday parties how many of
you have children show a hand okay do
you just dread birthday parties as much
as I do and I have to tell you after
having been to literally hundreds if not
thousands of children's birthday parties
my poor kids probably got shortchanged
their whole lives because I had seen
enough children's birthday parties to
last my whole life but it was very
interesting I ended up doing this for
six years I ended up doing about six
shows per weekend and by the time I was
a senior in high school I was actually
making about a thousand dollars a month
which was in 1976 dollars and for
perspective when I got out of Stanford
my first job with my degree I always
paid $1,000 a month so luckily I don't
value my Stanford education by the the
by the Delta between my income before
coming to Stanford and my income upon
leaving Stanford or it wouldn't have
been a very good investment but point
being this really taught me a lot it
taught me a lot about time management it
taught me a lot about the show must go
on I had to do the marketing I had to
collect the bills I had to update the
show I had to do all sorts of things and
as a one-woman operate
you really you had no one to depend on
by yourself and so I really learned a
lot about the importance of showing up
and being there and holding true to your
commitments so then I ended up back here
at Stanford I guess they like the idea
of having a puppeteer and they let me in
undergrad now one of the things I
learned and again for those of you still
here I'll give you a little tip because
now as a as a person who interviews a
lot of candidates and reads a lot of
resumes you think you did all the hard
work because you got into Stanford and
you know what we look at on your resume
it's the other stuff you do while you're
at Stanford that ends up being important
now that's not to say classes and
important keep going
stay in school get those degrees that's
great but the reality is I like most
people I ended up I had I decided to
pursue my passion my passion was English
with a specialty in creative writing
this was not a passion based on any kind
of idea about what kind of income I
wanted to have once I graduated from
Stanford and one of the things I
discovered upon graduating was first of
all I wasn't really all that great of a
writer and second of all there were just
not a lot of ads in the newspaper that
said we absolutely need a Creative
Writing major can you start tomorrow
so I actually a little bit of a
difficult time getting a job right out
of Stanford which I know that comes and
goes here with the economy sometimes
good sometimes not so good but
particularly for those of you who are
humanities majors I want to ask you to
raise your hands but I hope there's some
humanities majors in the room here I'm
hoping that I'm going to convince you
that actually being humanities major is
not such a bad thing because I ended up
with my English degree one of the things
I did is extracurricular I got very
involved in the Stanford daily and I did
some writing I was the production
manager I did it I did some photography
and as a result of that the first job I
got when I went out and looked for a job
they didn't want to hire me necessarily
as an English major but there were all
these brand new nascent computer
companies one of which was tandem
computers they were very big on company
culture they wanted to have somebody
come in and run an internal newspaper
for the company and that's what I was
hired to do and largely I was hired to
do that not only because I had a degree
in English from Stanford but
because I worked at the Stanford daily
so I was hired by tandem computers
proving that yes English majors can work
in tech and I went to tandem and I wrote
this newsletter and at first it was
really exciting and interesting and I
was learning a lot about computers I was
learning a lot about people I was
traveling to two field offices per month
I had great access to the CEO Jimmy try
big and all the other folks there they
were really I mean tandem was one of the
real high flyer companies in its day but
what I realized is after about a year I
got really tired of writing about what
other people were doing and I felt like
if I you know dropped off the face of
the earth the next day nobody would care
really I mean someone else might write
the paper but I wasn't really doing the
stuff that was on the front lines of the
company I wanted to be that person I
wanted the Victory's to be mine I wanted
to have those challenges and I felt like
in this role I was never going to get
that I looked around and everybody else
at tandem either who was getting ahead
they either had an engineering degree or
they had an MBA I decided that it was a
little late for me to go back and get an
engineering degree I know by the way be
a little expensive but I decided that
MBA thing looked like a really
interesting thing to do so once again I
find myself at Stanford I applied and
they let me in and I'm sure some days
they wondered why they did some days I
wondered why they did but I went off to
business school and while I was at
business school and again I have to set
the the timing for you guys because it's
hard for even me to think about how
different it was then versus versus now
when I was a Business School student
there were only three of us who had our
own personal computers and I had a
printer which made me super popular for
study groups because the only other way
you could actually use a computer and a
printer was good to go down the shared
facilities in the basement and wait
hours and all that kind of stuff so I
had a Northstar cp/m computer and a
printer because concurrently with being
in business school I also had the good
fortune to have a brilliant programmer
brother now he went to Cal which is a
little unfortunate
but maybe that's a good thing he was off
at the World Bank and he was working on
these things for the World Bank we're
over and over again they were asking him
to do the same thing over and over again
to take formulas create formulas put in
the various numbers from the various
countries that were being researched and
crank out these tables and spreadsheets
and my brother who will describe himself
as being an inherently lazy person and
if you could do something once and be
done why do it five times decided if he
could abstract the data from the formula
from the program that he could build
this thing called a spreadsheet and
again hard to imagine this was back you
know pre VisiCalc he could build
something that would basically do his
work over and over again and he would
never have to really write code anymore
he would just have to create data data
and formula for spreadsheets and so he
wrote that and the World Bank wasn't
that interested in utilizing it and so
he got a release from them and he
decided he wanted to take this and
publish it for the world of personal
computers which were just again just
coming out CPM Apple - this was the era
that that was happening so lucky for me
my brother didn't really want to run a
company he just wanted to write programs
and I he asked me well what do you think
we should do and I said well I think we
should start a company together I got a
great piece of advice at that time Pat
Becker one of the women that I worked
with the tandem computers said to me you
should be the CEO I said but it's my
brother's you know he's the coder he
came up with the idea and she said yeah
but what does he want to do I said well
he wants to sit in a room and code and
she said well but a CEO is the person
that the customer wants to talk to
number one you should be the CEO because
if your brother wants you to go meet
with customers customers want to meet
with the highest-ranking person in a
company you're the only person in the
company you may as well be the CEO and
the second reason she said is because
there are no women CEOs there just
aren't any and so if you're the CEO you
are going to be this interesting anomaly
and you will get more press attention
than you really deserve for the company
that you're running
was great advice and my brother being
extremely rational
I called him up I said hey I wanna be
CEO and here's why and I gave him my
arguments and he said okay that sounds
reasonable and that's how teamaker got
started so we actually started my second
year in Business School I took every
class I could that was around
entrepreneurship which at the time there
weren't that many wrote the business
client plan in one of the classes I
actually used the IBM pcs in the library
to make copies at night because we
didn't we couldn't afford a disk
duplicator so I'd go to the library
every night and I would make inventory
and in fact I actually got in trouble
with the guy who ran the library because
he thought I was illegally copying
software but I had little stickers with
the copyright notice and it had my
brother's name on it and so I showed him
my driver's license I'm like si no I'm
the sister of the guy who wrote the
program so it's okay so I didn't get
kicked out of school thankfully so I
started the company and let's just put
it this way
I was busy for the next 14 years so one
of my points for any of you who think
yeah I'm gonna go out start a company
we're gonna sell it to Facebook in two
years I'm gonna be rich I'll get my
sailboat you know that is not how it
usually works right this is how it
usually works that's actually an old
trade show picture I spent 14 years I
worked on the company we hired people my
brother and I didn't agree about the
direction for the company we split the
company up I took in two rounds of
venture capital ultimately after
bootstrapping it for many years we grew
it up to about 15 million in revenue
close to 100 people sold it I worked for
the acquire I've just described 14 years
of my life I then spent another 18 years
in what comes after that I ended up
going to work at Apple I was the VP of
Worldwide developer relations there
after I left my company successfully
transitioned it successfully got a
return for our investors which I'm very
proud of I became a venture capitalist I
became a board member and of course in
my fourth tour of duty at Stanford I
teach a class here MSE 178 please come
take it it's taught every quarter I
teach winter quarter that's my class
from last quarter so I've spent another
18 years out there in the world instead
of though being the player
you know instead of being the CEO I've
been the coach I've been a board member
and I've been a venture capitalist so
what I wanted to do is take 10-15
minutes and tell you ten things I've
learned from we won't even count how
many years a whole bunch of years of
doing this as an entrepreneur and then
as a mentor capitalist so the first
thing I want to talk about is and it was
actually Melinda Gates said this when
she spoke here at ETL she was talking
about how she walked by her daughter's
room and her daughter was young and she
was tying her shoes and she said this is
hard and then she said but I like hard
and I love that I love that line if
you're not doing something hard you're
wasting your time I can you know I can
tell you I've been through a lot of hard
things in my life and the greatest
feelings I have are when I get through
those hard things there's a lot of books
written about the topic of flow you know
that sense you're working on something
and it's right at the edge of your
capability and you're so engaged and
you're learning and you're you know
you're trying and you're failing and
you're doing all this and and the time
just flies by you look at your watch and
you're like oh my god five hours have
just passed that state of flow when
you're really testing yourself is a
wonderful thing and one of the things I
ask myself even even today maybe not
every day I try to do it every day but I
at least try to do it every week as I
say to myself what's something hard I
could tackle this week because the
reality especially about careers is it's
kind of funny that we work actually
really hard to eliminate hard stuff from
our careers right we want that like the
crews job or the dream job what most you
will find when you get there if you
actually do that you'll be bored so you
really need to find hard stuff and
tackle hard stuff and I would encourage
you and I think it's one thing that's
great about being an entrepreneur and
pulling a team together is it is hard
there's no safety net there's no regular
paycheck there's no one else looking out
for you you really have to do things on
your own but I can tell you from my
entire history of my career there's
nothing that's been as rewarding as
being an entrepreneur and coming through
the other side of that really really
hard stuff so look for the hearts
don't compromise your ethics this one's
really really difficult I actually just
wrote a blog post about something this
morning that I'll use as an example we
were in a really dark period of time at
tea maker and there was a sprinkler
malfunction and the sprinklers like
ruined all of our inventory in our
stockroom so we walked in they went off
at like 6:00 in the morning all the
inventory was ruined now the reality is
we were about to ship a new product and
that inventory was technically worthless
but our landlord didn't know that so we
had a long conversation because the
landlord actually even the landlord said
I don't care what it was worth I'm
insured just tell me what it was worth
and my insurance company will write you
a check and we thought long and hard
about that it was really tempting we
could have collected about a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and this is when
we were bootstrapped and this was twenty
something years ago so you can imagine
how tempting that was we thought about
it and we decided that we were going to
tell the truth because not only did we
know that inventory wasn't worth
anything but our employees knew that
inventory wasn't worth anything and we
felt that ethically if we were willing
to cheat on an insurance form then what
does that tell our employees it tells
our employees we condone cheating it's
ok to cheat file an expense report
that's not true take home an extra piece
of equipment if you want to because hey
we cheat you should cheat too so this is
one of those things it's so hard to
learn and I can just tell you again from
from my lessons of being out there in
the world for a long time when you do it
you will end up regretting it and I
don't know how else to describe it
you'll know the feeling you'll be
sitting there and you'll think I can
take this easy road I can say this thing
I can tell the customer something that
isn't really true about our product to
make the sale and sometimes you will get
away with it but sometimes you won't and
a lot of times you won't and it sets the
tone it sets the culture for the whole
company that you're building what you do
when you're faced with these ethical
decisions and so I would just encourage
you the more I the older I get the more
important this becomes to me and part of
it is just I like to sleep at night I
like to feel like I'm a good contributor
to the people that I work with
to the relationships that I build and
it's easier to do when you hold yourself
to some standards
trust your gut so I took this class in
business school called creativity and
business by Michael Rea and it was a
really great class it was kind of funny
it was like you know you're in business
school and you're thinking you're all
super like Business School Lee and you
go to this class and the first day says
ok now we're all gonna draw mangas
is that what they're called like are you
kidding me and then so every week he
would assign us something like one week
we were not supposed to speak for the
whole week
can you imagine being a business school
student and not speaking for a week one
week we were only supposed to do things
that were easy effortless and enjoyable
which was a really interesting lesson
because again most a business school is
not what I would call easy effortless
and enjoyable but what you discovered
when you were given that task is
sometimes if you just reordered the way
you did things they felt good at
different periods of time but the most
interesting week that we had is it was
called is it a yes or is it a no and for
that whole week we were supposed to make
the decision every any decision we were
facing you were supposed to go to sleep
at night write down what was the
question right go to sleep at night wake
up in the morning and go is it a yes or
is it a no and whatever came in your
mind that's what you were supposed to do
it was really fascinating and this is
one of those things I mean we are in the
era of big data big data big data if you
just had more data you could make better
decisions well I believe that is true
for some things but I don't believe it's
true for everything I also believe you
know if you're believer in things like
like the what the book blink says our
gut and our intuition is actually built
from months years whatever that time of
experience that we have sometimes even
subconsciously where we're observing
human nature and in our actions and when
we make a gut decision our gut has been
informed sometimes in ways we don't even
understand but I will tell you this I
trust my gut more than I used to and I
will continue to trust my gut and the
times I've done things where the data
said something else and I didn't go with
my gut
particularly around decisions around
people who to work with who to keep who
not to keep I regreted when I didn't
trust my gut so for what it's worth I'm
a gut person um speaking of people
people are the most important thing that
you're gonna do as an entrepreneur is
pick your team as much as you might be
brilliant and as much as you might be an
individual contributor and once in a
while there's an individual contributor
who's just so awesome that it works no
matter what the vast majority of
companies that that I know from having
worked with as an entrepreneur and then
as an investor succeed or die by the
quality of the team and there's an
interesting thing I see happen that
entrepreneurs tend to do and so let me
describe it to you okay you're young and
part of my your hardness you're young
and you don't know
right and so and you know that you don't
know about anything but you have an
idea to start a company and so then you
out and you think well I need to hire a
VP of Sales and you think well I don't
want to hire someone that knows a lot
more than I do because then I'm kind of
intimidated by that person so I think
I'll hire my roommate right who's like
the same age as me and knows about the
same amount of stuff as me and then you
want to hire a VP of something else an
HR HR person oh maybe I'll hire my
sister actually that was good for me cuz
that's what my brother did but okay it's
not all bad but what you will do is is
is you will surround yourself with
people that are familiar to you there's
a good reason to do that you trust them
you know them but there is sort of
sometimes a bad reason to do that which
is you're a little intimidated by people
who actually know things better than you
do but the problem with this strategy is
if you want to be the CEO and you want
to build out a company and you hire
everyone who doesn't know things if you
want to be the smartest person in the
room about everything you're gonna build
a crummy team do you really want to have
a VP of Sales who knows less about sales
than you do you really want to have a
CFO who knows less about financial
accounting than you do do you really
want to have a head of engineering who
knows less about engineering than you do
no of course not
you have to take the risk to find people
that are so much better at using these
things and then trust that in the
relationship your job being to manage
empower them make sure the team gets
along your job is not to no more than
that person and in fact I would argue if
you know more than that person then why
don't you just do the job so I really
believe in this
I believe in it even more as an investor
my goal my goal truly is to be the
dumbest person in the room
okay that sounds terrible doesn't it but
that is my goal right I want to invest
in people that are really bright and
really amazing and I might know some
things I can be helpful to them but I
really want to find those incredible
people and surround myself with them
because that's how real exciting
world-changing things get done um
this is another one that that has come
to me over time and again it's anchored
in a business school class so I took
this class called negotiation and
intervention and in negotiation one of
the lessons they taught us was they gave
us all these little forms and you were
either the buyer of us or the seller of
a used car and the class broke them into
small teams of you know two-person teams
or two-person opponents and you were all
given the same data and then you have to
negotiate the car transaction and at the
end you all reported at what price you
sold the car and there was an amazing
difference between the lowest price and
the highest price right I mean we were
all given the same data we broke off
into these little groups of two and we
went off into this negotiation and it
was vastly different that's a
transaction right that got transact when
I think about a transaction a
transaction is it's a zero-sum game I
want to make the most I can or I want to
pay the least I can I want the most of
the benefit I don't care who's on the
other side of the transaction
and my goal is to win my goal is to win
I don't believe anything's a transaction
anymore in life I believe everything's
about relationships so if you have a
transactional view in life the
transactional view is I want something
I'm gonna get it and I'm not going to
worry about anything that happens in the
future I'm gonna worry about right now
getting as much as I can if you have a
relationship view you have a very
different view
and again the business school term for
this which it's like the only sentence I
remember from business school that's how
important it was to me is the art of
negotiation is finding the maximal
intersection of mutual need so I'm gonna
say that again because I'd love it so
much it's the art of finding the maximal
intersection of mutual need so the first
idea is that life isn't a zero-sum game
right and it's almost never a zero-sum
game even about things like buying a
house or selling a used car there's
actually usually some other set of
circumstances that make it not just a
zero-sum game
and if I can walk into a transaction
with you and my goal is to not only make
myself better off but to make you better
off as well to find the maximal
intersection where both you and I
benefit as much as possible we're going
to have better outcomes and you're gonna
want to do business with me again and
that is really really important so in my
life I will just tell you I've been in
Silicon Valley all my life Silicon
Valley is a big place guess what you run
into the same people over and over and
over again and nowadays with your you
know your Facebook profile and your
likes and your and your Etsy rating and
your eBay rating and your you can tell I
shop a lot online there is no such thing
as a transaction anymore you are the sum
total of your transactions because those
form relationships and I would just
encourage you every time you meet with
someone if you think relationship
instead of transaction first of all not
everything is the opportunity for a
transaction and second of all if you
build a relationship with someone when
you actually need to have a transaction
with that person you'll know so much
more about them and they'll know so much
more about you and you will be able to
collaboratively help each other so I'm a
huge believer in this and and trust me
you'll all right you will all run into
each other again I could almost
guarantee it that's just the way the
world works so the way the world does
not work is like this and this is
particularly true for the how many of
you are undergrads undergrads undergo
okay a lot of undergrads so here's the
thing about your life until now as an
undergrad and I know I'm over typifying
and I'm not it's not to say
some of you haven't faced some horrible
things in your life but for the most
part you were in school and in school
there were rules and there were grades
and you understood the rules and if you
worked hard and you do this you could
get the grade and if you got the grade
and you did the right things you could
get in well Stanford even if you did all
that maybe you don't get into Stanford
but you guys obviously all got into
Stanford
so whatever it was you did you got into
Stanford and then you get here and it's
sort of still the same right you you
kind of know what you need to do to get
great grades now you're gonna go out in
the world and life doesn't work like
this you can't get on the escalator and
nowhere the escalator is and know how to
get it life actually is really really
random bad things will happen to you you
will fail things outside your control
will happen and so it's gonna happen so
let me give you a few ideas for how I
think you should you should lean in to
the fact that life doesn't work like
that
first of all expect that life is gonna
be messy right and and you know you
laugh about this you know the key to
happiness is to lower your expectations
but it's really kind of true like let me
just give you a really trivial trivial
example I travel internationally a lot
because I'm on the board of a company
based in London so I I take that flight
you know six times a year 12 times a
year when I travel internationally I
assume if I check baggage it will get
lost the flight will be late my car
won't arrive when I get there I assume
everything wrong with the with the
flight will happen and therefore when it
actually happens I'm not stressed right
I've put a change of clothes actually I
just always have a carry-on I've learned
to pack very light because I'd rather
just have my stuff with me I don't
schedule a meeting for two hours after I
land because if the flights two hours
late it screws up the whole thing I
expect mess and when I expect mess and
it doesn't happen I'm pleasantly
surprised so one of these I would say
about life and especially when you've
had some bad things happen to you is 95%
of your stress is self-inflicted because
you will do things like build you will
build expectations around future events
that are not better
that are unrealistic I had an
entrepreneur once and he had a lot of
entrepreneurs like this but one in
particular he would always build his
plan such that everything had to go
perfectly right and I would just say to
him
nothing ever all goes perfectly right
and every year wouldn't go perfectly and
then he'd submit his plan for the next
year I'm like yep once again
everything's not gonna go perfectly and
if you assume everything's gonna go
perfectly and it doesn't bad things will
happen to you like you'll run out of
money when you haven't reached the next
milestones that allow you to get funding
so don't let that happen you expect that
life is gonna be messy and when life is
messy you need to get up again and I
know this sounds like a Hallmark card
and I'm sorry it does but it does but
it's the truth it's not how many times
you fall down it's how many times you
get back up and it is one of those
simple things but it's a simple law if
you fall down and stay down you will be
down for the rest of your life if and
it's one of the things I think it's so
great about ETL there have been so many
speakers who've gotten up here and said
you know I got fired my child died my
spouse left to me my company went out of
business they tell you these terrible
things and then they figure out a way to
pick up and move on and that to me has
been very very motivating because when I
go through those terrible things and
I've gone through some of those terrible
things you realize that other people
have made it through and that you're
gonna make it through to and so I just
would encourage you when you go through
those moments
remember this go back and look at ETL
speeches you can go find all those
terrible things that other people have
been through and it'll make you feel
better because you'll know that you can
get back up again the other thing is
that in that random stuff good things
happen
and not all random is bad this is
another thing I'm sorry to single out
Stanford and Stanford students but
Stanford students really want to get
everything right all the time right one
of the things that just drives me crazy
about my students is that is they'll
have like three okay I'm not gonna pick
on anyone in the room but let's just say
there are people that are currently
sitting on three job offers
for a friggin internship for the summer
and they're worrying about which one to
take which one will be the best on my
resume which one will afford me the best
opportunity which whatever I'm like oh
for god sakes pick any one of them
they're all fine there's no difference
it doesn't matter and in fact if you
pick one that's bad and it goes out of
business and you get fired that might be
the greatest thing that ever happens to
you right because you will learn
something really amazing that you may
not work learn sitting in a really safe
job in a really big company so this is
just one of those things if you again if
you read I went through divorce so I
read a lot of books about divorce and
happiness and all that kind of stuff I
went through my midlife crisis and one
of the things that that one of the books
on happiness it said if you ask people
like in the last five years what's the
worst thing that's happened to you and
in the last five years what's the best
thing that's happened to you for many
people they are the same thing and they
are things like losing a spouse getting
cancer getting fired
having my company go out of business it
is shocking when you actually go ask
real people what has moved their life in
the most positive direction that it
often is those things so sometimes bad
things can be good and oh by the way
something's really good happened to you
when you allow randomness into your life
go to a meeting but you don't know what
you know that you don't necessarily know
what's gonna happen
meet somebody you know somebody Sesame G
hi do you have a lot of ways to spend
your time why do you teach at Stanford
and I say well you know Stanford does a
really good job of collecting a bunch of
super interesting people and then they
further self-select by reading about my
class and by the time they show up in my
class they probably want to know those
people and I don't know why I'm not
picking them they're actually picking me
it's random but you know I've been
teaching here for five years and I have
to say that I've made some really close
relationships with the students I've had
in my class so that's one of those just
random I left myself open to random
opportunity and it turns out to be a
really good thing and the last thing any
Downton Abbey fans in the room come on
admit it okay a few this is this is a
lady Grantham's mother right real name's
Shirley MacLaine she's a very famous
actress she is Warren Beatty
sir she's written some really
interesting books she believes in
reincarnation and a whole bunch of other
interesting things she's walked the
Campostella she's an interesting person
but she coined this thing called the
2046 knee roll and I'm gonna close what
this is just something I've learned and
a piece of advice I love this rule and
the rule goes like this at 20 you're
constantly worrying about what other
people think of you at 40 you wake up
and you say I'm not going to give a damn
what other people think of me anymore
and at 60 you come to realize that no
one's actually thinking of you now I
love I love this and I you know if
there's there's one thing I want you to
remember today I want you to remember
this 20 40 60 rule because here's why
because nobody is actually thinking
about you and I want that to empower you
because there's good news and there's
bad news in this right the bad news is
nobody's thinking about you know what's
waking up nobody's waking up every day
going I wonder if Heidi Roizen is
fulfilled in her job today I wonder I
wonder if she's making enough money I
wonder if she's happy within her
relationships no one is doing that
probably not even your parents maybe a
little bit your parents especially if
they're still paying for you but for the
most part nobody's thinking about you
your boss is not thinking about you your
peers are not thinking about you you
need to think about you you need to be
your own advocate if you're in a job you
don't like you need to think about
changing it you cannot sit in your
office and wait for someone to come and
bring you an answer if you are in
something you need to empower yourself
to go do something else because no one
else is gonna do it for you but let me
tell you the flip side of that nobody's
really thinking about you we all torture
ourselves thinking about what other
people must think of us I'll give you an
example I you know as I said I travel I
travel a lot for business I'd inevitably
get somewhere and I'd have the wrong
pair of shoes for the outfit or one time
I actually had one blue shoe and one
brown shoe because I'd bought two pairs
of the same but different colors and in
the dark I put them in my suitcase they
were two different shoes my jacket would
be wrinkled all the time right I'd get
pulled myself together and I'd kind of
look a little scruffy and
I would be so worried about that I be
worried what are people gonna think of
me that I didn't pull myself together or
whatever and then I thought to myself
one day it occurred to me I thought have
you ever been in a meeting with someone
and halfway through the meeting I
thought well even though this person's
really smart they have a wrinkle in
their jacket so they must not be very
good right no you never think that way
right you never think about this stuff
and the other thing we do and again not
singling out the women but a little bit
we women worry about this even more oh
god what did I say in that meeting oh
god did I did I raise my hand and say
something that might have been dumb or
did I make a faux pas oh my god I
introduced that person and I use the
wrong name right
I can I can torture myself for weeks
over a mistake like that
I used to torture myself for weeks over
mistakes like that and I finally learned
you know what nobody else is thinking
about me that much they've got their own
stuff they're thinking about so don't
let it worry you that much am i Mike my
closing recommendation to you is you
have to be your own advocate but when
you make mistakes don't worry about it
because no one's thinking about you as
hard as you're thinking about yourself
so with that almost right on time and
let's go for it
um so I guess it was a little curious
see you said people aren't thinking but
I mean I think that's not true in today
feed given like there's so much video
coverage over like everyone's actions of
like constantly yeah and I wouldn't want
people not to think because that means
I'm not adding value or my up creating
any so it is sort of a contradictory
comment right people are I mean I blog
right
I sent out a blog post I put it on
Facebook I put it on LinkedIn I tweet
about it and I want people to think
about me and I want people to comment on
it and I get excited when I see how many
thousands people read my blog and made a
comment and five minutes from now
they're not gonna think about me anymore
if anything today the more there's so
much coming at you right that you can
only you know if you think about today
like how many people you know versus a
hundred years ago how many people you
would know and if we count people you
know like like Kim card
you probably don't personally know do
you know campaign okay
you probably don't personally know Kim
Kardashian but when I say her name you
know what she looks like and you know
she just got married and you know like
so your brain is full of stuff about
lots and lots of other people so I
believe that on the one hand yes we know
so much more and we think so much more
about other people but at the end of the
day it gets distilled down to what
sticks in your brain what's important
and so I mean my argument being one hand
don't don't worry too much because
people do move on I mean it's
interesting to me I'm on the board of
don't hold this against me there I'm on
the board of the Daily Mail mail online
which is let's just euphemistically call
it pop culture journalism and it's
interesting you know and the articles
get posted based on the popularity of
the article right and there's a whole
bunch of big data that's going on behind
there and it's very interesting to watch
the arc of a story and how it will
occupy everyone's minds and then a few
weeks later it will be gone
right because we've moved on we just
move on to other things so it is it is a
there's it's a it's two it's two sides
of the same coin and I think what you
have to think about is what is it that
you're in and what are you going to
stand for what are you gonna be
consistent about and what's gonna leave
a lasting impression and I do believe
consistency is one of those things right
I have a very consistent voice in how I
interact how I blog how I do things so
that people can read 10 of my posts and
at the end of the 10 posts if somebody
said what do you think of Heidi I think
they're gonna have a very consistent
view of me because I'm I'm I have kind
of the same the same things over time so
maybe I don't know maybe that's the
answer
sure yes so I'm curious if you could
just dive a little deeper into you're
talking about the difference between
transactions and relationships and how
relationships have really worn out man
yeah I when I go to a gas station I
don't have a relationship with that gas
station I just want that track
transaction
yeah I can shoot down yeah where are you
kind of coming wait there's no human
involved in that transaction right I'm
talking about human really what you are
but today you can get gas without having
a transaction with another person right
but I would argue I'm trying to think of
an example okay go to Starbucks right
you go to Starbucks and you think of it
as a transaction and you think of that
person as a nonhuman
and you're grumpy and you say give me my
double half-caf Efrafa whatever
thing
and you do that every day right and then
one day you walk in and you forgot your
wallet you're not gonna have a coffee
you are in every day and you're nice and
you're like how are you and you get to
know the person's name and you are
polite to them and you think about I
have a relationship with this person I
may not know them I may see them once a
day when I get my Starbucks but why not
be a nice person why not acknowledge
them as a human being I will bet you if
you walk in there without your wallet
one day you're gonna walk out with a
coffee anyway now should you do it
because you wanted that coffee no I mean
I think you should do it because it
makes you feel better as a human being
but I would argue even the most trivial
things that you think are transactions
and not relationships you will run into
almost all those people again I mean
even at a gas station the person you
know behind the counter is probably the
same person you don't go to a different
gas station every single time right
embarrassingly like the people at Neiman
Marcus all know me but you know you do
you build relationships with people all
over the place and I think that really
enriches your life too now again the
other thing about capacity there's only
so many you know you do have to edit
this is the problem is we don't have
infinite capacity so you know my
approach is on the one hand I try to be
a good person and recognize the humanity
and every other person I interact with I
don't care if they are the gas station
attendant or I don't care what role
they're in if they are a human being I
try to treat them with the same respect
I would want to be treated and why not
make their day happier instead of more
miserable right but the flipside is that
I can only have deep relationships with
it with a smaller set of people
invest more significant time in those
people and you have to make those
trade-offs and over your life sometimes
it'll change yes hi so I agree to speak
about like energy and sort of make an
extrovert or an introvert and one of the
things that I was curious that when I'm
hearing you talk about you know all
these positive interactions and bring
good energy and also being available to
your students to opportunity I do all of
that but I'm I get my energy from being
alone and I'm like working on my own
stuff so I find it exhausting in a
certain point yep and I was curious as
to how you manage to balance that like
keeping your energy for yourself well
putting out so much positive and I get
that is but that is a great question and
I I'm actually I like to spend long
periods of time by myself I'm I'm very
you know if you ask my daughter I read a
lot you know I'm very quiet if I had a
really busy week and someone says would
you do this week I'm like nothing I did
nothing I sat in my room and I read a
book all weekend I think one of the
things that we forget to do and and I'll
close on this because I have two minutes
left in it was actually a slide I was
going to talk about and then I took it
out because I had too many slides the
most important thing you have in your
life is your time because you can't make
more of it you're gonna run out you can
do things to leverage it with money and
assistance and all of that but at the
end of the day time is the thing you
can't make anymore of so you have to be
really sensitive about how you spend
your time and one of the things people I
think do is they are there they're like
bad at understanding that certain things
take time
for example and I won't ask for a show
of hands but how many people in this
room have more than a thousand emails in
your ambass c't okay I'm hearing a
little bit of chuckles in here you don't
have to identify yourself you people
have a time management problem okay
because email is a fact it's a reality
and you have to learn how to answer it
or shut it down make it go away but you
have to figure that out because if you
have a thousand unanswered emails in
your investment then you're gonna miss
something important right so the thing
that I was tell people say so hard on
how you do this I say well I plan I
don't schedule more than five hours of
things in a day because I need
hours to do email and answer calls and
read and do the things that actually
makes me inform well I don't have time
to do that well of course you do you
just have to not do those other things
right so one of the things I would
really encourage people to really think
about every use of your time and give it
all equal weight for starters and and
recognize that some that grunt work
takes time right reading takes time all
of these things take time figure out
what your balance is and figure out what
you're gonna let in your life and leave
those spaces for you to be reflect and
get enough sleep and do all those other
things I also understand that some of
you are like okay Heidi that's really
nice but you're a 56 year old venture
capitalist and I'm a Stanford graduate
student who has a start-up on the side
and I haven't slept in three weeks okay
I get that I once was an entrepreneur
and I was not I did not live a very
balanced life so I realized that part of
what I'm saying is I think we do live
our lives in a serial fashion and I
think there are times you will go
through a period like that and there are
times and and I will tell you right now
if you're in that but it's flow and
you're really excited about doing it you
can run on that for a long time right
other things will fall by the wayside
relationships and family and things and
hopefully they'll be there when you need
them because I don't necessarily think
that's it that's a good way to run but I
do think that that set aside and even
when you're in that situation if you
don't allow yourself some open space
you're not going to have those good
random things happen to you as well so
it's a really challenging thing but I
would say the biggest thing is people
have a fantasy that there's a whole
bunch of stuff that takes no time
including relationships and
communication when I would argue that if
you ask people at the end of their lives
you know if you read all the happiness
books you know what they say about the
meaning of life is it's meaningful work
and meaningful relationships and yet
people don't invest time in
relationships and so there's just
something fundamentally misaligned there
and with that I'm out of time hope
you'll join me in thanking professor
road
thank you
you